on behalf of our entire team we hope
you're thrilled with what you've seen so
far from battlefield 2042
but this is just the beginning we have
so
much more to show you battlefield 2042
is built up by three epic experiences
firstly of course all that warfare that
we showed you earlier
secondly hazard zone that will show off
later this year
and now a new community driven
experience that we're happy to share
with you today
built by our old friends over at triple
effect
formerly dice la it's an experience
designed from community feedback it's an
experience we've dreamt about building
for over a decade so
let's have a look
[Music]
[Music]
gotta step it up boys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's the sound of them going
[Music]
back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
nice luntable
yes
this looks incredible there's so many
crazy things happening in this trailer
we got knives versus defibrillators we
got soldiers from every air i have
so many questions so let's bring on an
expert here to help us out is the
general manager of ripple effect we've
got
christian grass welcome christian hey
austin thanks for having me super
excited to be here
of course thank you for being here now
that trailer absolutely
ridiculous like what the hell did we
just see so what you just saw was the
battlefield portal it's a new community
driven experience that gives
players the freedom to write their own
rules and shape
their own battlefield you can mix and
match content from battlefield 1942
back company 2 bf3 and battlefield 2042
to create brand new game modes then you
can share and discover those on the
portal platform
and that's just what's coming at launch
this is a real love letter to the fans
from our incredible team and oh and this
is your squad
yes this is the fantastic ripple effect
team and they deserve all the credit in
the world for creating this
great experience we've had so much fun
bringing back some of the most beloved
vehicles
gadgets weapons and maps from past
titles
well thank you all huge huge credit to
this amazing team and
everyone who's made battlefield 2042
possible all right so to bring it back
when you say
beloved maps we're talking caspian
border yes eureka harbor
yes el alamein yes el alamein is also
included it's actually my all-time
favorite map
plus we have no shark canal battle of
the bulge
and valparaiso and of course
all seven of the new epic scale maps
already announced for 2042
they're also playable in portal i love
it i love it but this is more than just
maps right
absolutely portal is a chance for the
community to drive the platform there's
a whole slate
of customization options and even an
advanced logic editor for you to play
around with
tools that were previously only
available to us on the development team
so that trailer it was just packed with
a ton of crazy moments
so i'm curious how wild can we actually
get with portal
you can get pretty wild yeah okay so can
i pit
world war ii against 2042 yes
okay okay uh what about game modes can i
make an infection mode
where it's me against a ton of super
fast soldiers with knives
absolutely okay uh what about shoddy
snipes but
but not just regular shoddy snipes like
like like a gun game with a whole bunch
of shoddy snipes from all throughout
history
that is a very specific idea there
austin but yes actually you can
baton three for three bring it home can
i play
as a penguin with a flamethrower a
penguin with a flamethrower yeah
no i mean look there are some limits
it's not a level editor you can't edit
the maps themselves
and no you can't play as a penguin with
a flamethrower all right that's that's
fine it's fine i had to ask
but it does sound like there's a ton to
play around with oh yes
the options are pretty deep and we're
committed to working with the community
to build out this suite of tools and
content as the game evolves
we want this experience to go where you
want to take it
we see the sandbox as a big part of the
future of battlefield 2042
well i assume that the community is
going to have a field day with this
i really hope players will embrace
portal that's who we built it for
in fact we gave a sneak peek to a few
members of the community
to see what they could come up with oh
okay i assume my invitation got lost in
the mail but that's fine that's fine
let's check it out two teams and two
vips
but only one way to score this is vip
fiesta
by courage it's the us factions of
battlefield 3
and bad company 2 facing off on erica
harbour with
24 players and random loadouts
die and you'll redeploy with an all-new
loadout track down the enemy vip
and make it count
all bring the power of 2042 to caspian
border
and take on the forces of 1942 this
is quality versus quantity by gabitron
a small squad from 2042 are taking on 32
players from 1942
the future's got the hardware but the
past got the numbers
destroy those m coms
but do it before your tickets are up
you're not getting them back
unless you clear the sector
not enough memes fine set up on orbital
for the fight of your lives
with robot man by redacted
20 duck sized eodbots one horse-sized
t91
settle your battlefield debates on who
wins what
come on dude robot man what this looks
so much
fun but i need to know just pretend like
the cameras aren't here just mean you
who's redacted can't tell you that sorry
but what i can tell you is that we're so
excited for the players
to create or simply discover their
favorite new way to play battlefield
and we can't wait to explore and try out
the thousands of experiences
our community will build once they have
the tools in their hands
and we get our hands on portal at launch
right yes porter will be available
at launch day one along with a bunch of
pre-made modes for you to try right away
okay this is this is fantastic now
christian before you go
let me make sure that i have all of this
straight so on top of all the content
and maps that have already been
announced
we also get content from battlefield
1942
bad company 2 and battlefield 3
including six of the best maps of all
time
and all that can be sliced diced and
mixed together in portal and then we
still have hazard zone coming later this
year
yes that's exactly what i'm telling you
austin if you've always been a fan
or if you've never played battlefield
before we want battlefield 2042 to be
the ultimate battlefield experience
christian just just thank you
thank you my pleasure austin i'll see
you on the battlefield
i